you guys have mentioned that there has
been a level of communication with Demar
writing I I'm curious what what are you
all able to see that that he's
understanding or processing what all has
happened to him these last couple of
days uh you know we've discussed um you
know within what happened
um he's not quite to the point where we
can have a conversation because again
still has the breathing tube in
um and is able to communicate with yeses
and no's by shaking his head not in his
head or with uh with brief notes
um you know we uh he was expressed
surprised that he had been you know not
with us with the world for two days uh
and uh you know we've talked to him
about all the support that's been given
from Cincinnati Buffalo and really
across the country uh for him and his
family during this time you know his uh
his mom and dad have talked to him about
what has happened and we expect that
we'll continue to have ongoing
conversations with him you know and
again his first you know first question
that he wrote when he when he started to
awaken was it was that we went so we
know that he's really it's not only that
the lights are on we know that he's home
and it appears that all all the
cylinders are firing within his brain
which is greatly gratifying for all of
us for the nurses and the respiratory
therapists and the care team that's
going to decide I was wondering if you
could just add a bit more context on
kind of what next steps will look like
for recovery from DeMar you know you
mentioned how
um his health puts him in a good
position but just from a human
standpoint just kind of what is the
process like from here
um for him yeah from ours that's a great
question
um and there are many many steps still
ahead of him from our standpoint we
would like to see him continue to
improve uh to be completely breathing on
his own and then to be you know ready to
be discharged from the hospital so those
are the immediate next steps as we go
for his care you know his family has
been with him at his bedside as a
members of Buffalo Bill organization
really since this all began and we
really want to get him home today and so
those will be the immediate next steps
and then we'll talk about uh you know
potential plans for the future our team
involved a significant number of the
Care team involved in in helping with Mr
Hamlin on the field on Monday night uh
he was attended to by four of our
emergency physicians serving in the
various roles as uh the airway physician
the visiting team medical liaison uh a
neurotrauma consultant as well as one of
the team positions for the Cincinnati
Bells the Cincinnati Bengals
um as as everybody knows Mr Hamlin
suffered a cardiac arrest on the field
and it was promptly recognized by the
Buffalo Bills medical staff and that
allowed for a very immediate
resuscitation on the field he was
promptly resuscitated it did require CPR
and defibrillation and at which point he
was transported to the University of
Cincinnati Medical Center where he was
met by Dr by Dr Prince and the trauma
team as well as our emergency medicine
colleagues
he was managed and resuscitated and
worked up in the emergency department
had some additional tests in the Ed and
in the hospital and then has been
managed in the surgical ICU as Dr Prince
said
it's been a long and difficult road for
the last three days he has been very
sick and and has made a fairly
remarkable recovery and Improvement to
the point as as Tim noted he is now
demonstrating that sign of good
neurologic recovery as well as overall
clinical Improvement as has been
previously reported related to not just
his vital signs but a lot of his other
individual organ recovery
he he was intubated on the field had a a
what I would deem a textbook
resuscitation
um on the field from again immediate
bystander CPR uh defibrillation Airway
management and then transport to the
hospital it's critical that we do that
resuscitation at the scene of where a
cardiac arrest is that pretends the best
recovery there was no um trach or
um or or Airway other than the
endotracheal tube that he has as for the
long-term recovery again we're focused
on the the right now and he still has a
little ways to go in terms of Liberation
from the ventilator and I think that
that's going to be our Focus right now
in terms of helping them to recover
liberate continue to get uh stronger and
rehabilitate but it is entirely too
early to project into the future